SCP-682 Vs SCP-067.
While this particular cross test was never
expected to destroy or even harm the Hard
to Destroy Reptile, researchers figured that
this all-telling Fountain pen might glean
valuable information about the monster.
SCP-067 is a pen that causes
people to compulsively
write or draw about themselves.
When the pen was given to SCP-682, it was
horribly surprised when it began drawing a
complex image on the floor.
When the image was done, it threw the pen
across the room.
The resulting picture was a self-portrait
of SCP-682, sitting atop a legion of dead
Roman soldiers, marked as the Ninth Legion
- which had historically,
mysteriously disappeared.
They may have been no closer to defeating
SCP-682, but at least they solved that mystery.